you come onto our campus you know that
this is a very international campus
we're all very multicultural we all are
very inclusive
so i think for you to come into our
campus with such an inflammatory
question that's based on a policy made
by somebody who is called mexicans
rapists everything you've just said is
inaccurate
wise and accurate well first off it's
not a policy that donald trump created
he didn't call all mexicans rapists and
by the way we have a permit to be here
and we're not exploiting anyone's labor
people are free to sit down whether they
choose to discuss the topic or not by
the way there's nothing offensive about
the idea of building the wall half of
america supports the idea everything
that you just said is factually
verifiably inaccurate and if people are
going to paint all of their opposition
as racist as these people have done here
i think that there's a great disservice
to dialogue here in the united states
we're trying to engage in dialogue